Buenas tardes según Fuentes del
Ministerio Público la fiscal general de
Perú Patricia Benavides le preguntó a la
presidenta Dina boluarte porque el
ejército y la policía dispararon contra
los manifestantes y población que se
encontraba desarmada la posición de la
mandataria peruana es que ella ordenó
que se evitaran las muertes Durante los
operativos de control de las protestas y
además habría señalado que ella no tiene
ningún tipo de injerencia sobre los
mandos militares y que ellos responden a
sus respectivos comandos pero esta
versión es contradecida por organismos
de Derechos Humanos quienes denuncian
que al interior de gobierno de ida
boluarte
operativos para reprimir las protestas y
según los organismos de Derechos Humanos
eso querría decir que tanto la policía
como el ejército habrían obedecido a una
decisión política días atrás la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
señaló en base a pruebas y testimonios
obtenidos que los hechos ocurridos
califican como una masacre
internacional 20 de 25 casos analizados
podrían calificar como ejecuciones
extrajudiciales bueno Francisco Y ahora
qué escenarios podrían esperarle a la
mandataria peruana
según algunos juristas la presidenta
Dina boluarte podría ser condenada hasta
el 35 años de prisión por cargos de
homicidio calificado y lesiones graves
si es que es hallada culpable por un
tribunal Mientras tanto en el congreso
de Perú la subcomisión de acusaciones
constitucionales Tratará esta tarde una
denuncia constitucional contra la
mandataria peruana y otros funcionarios
de su gobierno por los presuntos delitos
de homicidio calificado y Mientras tanto
en el frente externo la mandataria
peruana y los principales funcionarios
de este gobierno han sido denunciados
ante la Corte Penal Internacional por
presuntos delitos de crímenes de lesa
humanidad el camino para Dina boluarte y
sus abogados se torna complicado